[Music]
[Applause]
so we spent a little bit of time trying
to figure out what's going on with jim
harbaugh tom pelicero the nfl network he
broke the news that harbaugh is going to
fly into minnesota like now it gets real
you know it's one thing if hey i'm
hearing maybe he's reaching out to the
raiders or vice versa and now
you have him going to minnesota now this
changes things or it feels a little bit
more real but uh i'm don't take my word
take sam webb's word for it he's the
publisher of the michigan insider.com on
24 7 sports morning show host of sports
talk 10 50 the ticket sam joins us now
sam uh thanks for joining us on short
notice so
jim jim harbaugh going to minnesota
means what to you
it means that he's serious about this
job
you know you're right dan that this is
different than past
sort of i think media driven
media driven story lines i i don't think
that jim harbaugh really pursued this
in years past but make no mistake he is
going after this job
it he could have silenced this
quickly he didn't i think there's a
message in that and that this is so
public that he is going to minnesota at
a time where he is trying to hire a
defensive coordinator i know a lot of
people are making a big deal about about
him traveling there on national signing
today they aren't signing any prospects
uh coming up on wednesday but it is
transfer portal time there are things
that you're doing to prepare for spring
ball to prepare roster management right
his focus is on minnesota he is going
there to get this job that makes this
different and everyone that i talk to
whether they be around ann arbor agents
in the nfl that i talk to they all
expect that if the minnesota vikings
offer jim harbaugh this job he will take
it
i thought michigan was his dream job he
just like
what what is what has transpired here in
the last uh 12 months yeah man it's it's
funny i get that question a lot and
look i'm
i can only try to get in jim harbaugh's
head so much i don't know him as well as
his family or his friends that have been
around him
his his entire life but i've gotten to
know him as well as a media member could
get to know him over the past seven
years
and what i could say
is when he came to town
it was like he was the princess zamunda
they were throwing the rose petals at
his feet right
and
you get six years into the process
you have real adversity
and you have
you have the people who anointed you
from day one sort of turning on you and
it sort of reminds you that
while you came home
and this is your place
this is a job and support can erode here
like it erodes anywhere so being on the
precipice of losing your job has a way
of
being sort of reminding you or giving
you that perspective i think it's that i
think that realizing that there might be
another opportunity that's better for
him personally
uh there might be a situation that's
better for his family
uh the window will never be wider than
it is now he's coming off his his
biggest success at michigan
there are a slew of teams or were a slew
of teams that he had connections to the
iron is never going to be hotter than it
is now he's 58 now it only gets harder
to get an nfl job after this so i think
the convergence of all of those things
makes this an ideal time and while i
think he's loyal to michigan he loves
michigan i think probably in his mind he
he will say i got him back
i got him back to
being in the picture in the national
title hunt i left it better than i found
it
now i can do something that might be
better for me personally might be better
for my family i think that's how he's
probably looking at it but the irony of
this is sam
he beat ohio state and because he beat
ohio state he became
a little bit more of a hot candidate if
he loses to ohio state then it's uh same
old story
he beats ohio state and that might be
the reason why he's back you know on the
front burner
it is ironic it's ironic in that you
know his name was out there last year
like it had never been before and there
were no real takers but again i think us
it's also the case that in the cycle you
just mentioned he's he's this hot name i
think it's all relative
i think it's hot relative to what he was
last year when there were no takers now
i mean how many jobs did you have open
eight and while jim harbaugh's name was
attached to a bunch of these jobs in the
media
you talked to nfl people
and his name wasn't like really
in the mix for all these jobs
why is this people keep asking why is he
dragging this out so long
you take it out as long as it takes for
a team to show real interest right so
this is the team showing real interest
it happens to be in the 23rd hour it's
related to questi adofo mensa getting
that job a guy that he worked with in
san francisco so this i think even more
so even as much as beating ohio state
puts you on the radar it's also i think
really revealing that it took this it
took to this point in this cycle for him
to get a real taker i think that's
another reason why if you're him man you
better jump on this train while it's
here
is jim harbaugh coaching minnesota
or michigan next season
i think that's all about what minnesota
wants to do if minnesota offers him that
job i i i really believe he will take it
okay i think it's a it's a prime
opportunity
i think he's confident in where he left
it i think he probably sees a successor
on his staff he probably will will speak
up for one of them i imagine before he
goes i think he's feeling pretty good
about michigan state and about
michigan's state and then i think it
with that it gives him comfort in moving
on to the next thing for him so if
because this is what i can't quantify
i don't know
if they're going to offer him the job it
seems like it's leaning that way people
i talked to say that he's questionful
men's number one target if that's the
case and he knocks this interview out of
the park and they offer him the job he
will take it
good stuff sam thanks for joining us
all right thanks a lot dan appreciate it
that's sam webb publisher of the
michigan insider.com
24 7 sports and morning show host of
sports talk 1050.